Шановні колеги безумовно європейська
Солідарність буде підтримувати
приєднання України до членства в банку
Ради Європи і це ще один спосіб для нас
мати допомогу вільного світу але хочу
нагадати що ми дійсно весь час
розраховуємо на те що вільний світ
країни вільного світу будуть нам
допомагати і будуть стояти разом із нами
всій боротьбі і Рада Європи є однією з
тих інституцій і в якій успішно в
парламентській асамблеї Ради Європи
працює українська делегація багато
фракційна багато політична українська
делегація від Верховної Ради України але
що відбувається ми бачимо що на жаль
правила в українській Верховній Раді не
для всіх не однакові для всіх і ми
бачимо що тим депутатам навіть якщо вони
якісно провадять міжнародну роботу але з
якими не згодна керівництво парламенту
чи можливо керівництво країни
перекривається шлях до виконання прямих
обов'язків у Раді Європи в
парламентській асамблеї Ради Європи так
нашого колегу Олексія Гончаренка не було
допущено як члена парламентської
асамблеї Ради Європи до трьох відряджень
в рамках виконання повноважень його як
члена Ради Європи це неприпустимо це без
чунство це має бути
припинено Ми висловлюємо засудження і
різкий протест проти таких дій
керівництва Верховної Ради України
керівництво парламентської асамблеї Ради
Європи звернулося до парламенту України
припинити порушувати демократичні норми
і ми сподіваємося що країна яка сьогодні
стікає кров'ю за свій вибір за те що
вона хоче бути демократичною і
європейською буде все-таки дотримуватися
усіх норм в тому числі Ради Європи дякую
Шановні колеги скільки було згадано
керівництво Верховної Ради А я відношуся
до керівництва Верховної Ради Я просто
інформую вас шановні колеги зокрема про
деякі питання щодо порядку оформлення
відряджень ви знаєте що відрядження
надаються народним депутатам відповідно
до положення про відрядження і за 10
днів особа має надати заяву так от щодо
візьмемо секундочку ви я чув вашу
позицію а тепер я показую те що зі
скрінами У мене є ваша заява на
відрядження з дев'ятого надійшла
09.05 о 14:30
положення розпорядження ще раз ви можете
говорити що завгодно я вам показую а
розпорядження прийшло десятого тому
Шановні колеги давайте порядок починати
з себе і правила для того щоб їх
дотриматись Дякую переходимо далі
Олексій Гончаренко європейська
Солідарність шановні друзі шановний
голова Верховної Ради Я прошу вас ми між
нами Можуть бути різні відносини може
бути різні там що завгодно але не треба
брехати один одному в очі ви чудово
знаєте Я чудово знаю що я подав заяву на
відрядження 21 квітня ви чудово знаєте
що ваш заступник пан Корнієнко не
підписував мені цю не ставив свою візу
коли нема візи заступника голови вона не
йде до вас формально Але ж я подався
вчасно друге це кажу це надзвичайно
важливо ми з вами особисто пане голово
зустрілися 3 травня разом з делегацією
України в парі там була зустріч багато
було депутатів і я там до вас 3 травня
звернувся що залишається один день
Підписати мені розпорядження на
конференцію ви цього не зробили і це є
правда і брехати не треба і на
національному Марафоні брехати не треба
Я розумію що мене на національний
марафон не пускають Я розумію що мене
туди нікуди ніколи не запросять Але ж це
не привід тоді обріховати мене там до
речі якщо є совість національного
марафону дайте можливість мені сказати
як була справа завершую Я завжди
працював за кордоном на державу тільки
на державу виключно на державу буду далі
так працювати вас прошу не ганьбити
країну нікому нічого не додала що
сьогодні Президент парє пише листи
Верховну Раду як Україна порушує свої
зобов'язання
порушує зобов'язання члена країни-члена
Ради Європи так немає бути ми не маємо
ганьбити країну ніколи Які в нас з вами
не були суперечки маємо поважати країною
наш прапор і працювати на нього